[Music]
all right guys
this is it this is the beginning of a
journey you guys are joining us into
our baby's life all right so we're
heading to our very first prenatal
appointment today is july 8th
i am i believe seven weeks pregnant now
but today we'll for sure find out what
the due date will be we're just so
excited and nervous and all kinds of
emotions because
we've been wanting to
actually
make it to this appointment to see like
you know we could hear a heartbeat
make sure it's a nice and healthy
pregnancy because you know we're
we've been traumatized
from the last time yeah we're gonna make
it this far last time yeah we did it
this almost feels like the finished line
like we've seen we finally made it to
the first appointment i know oh my god
so we found out on june 21st right is
when we found out i was pregnant and so
since then every day i
like we both have just been like
watching every symptom making sure like
i actually took a couple pregnancy to
test afterwards because i was cramping
and i was like spotting tmi but i was
just like oh my gosh
are we gonna lose this one too like i
was so terrified and yeah the pregnancy
test would come back and they're strong
and that means there was a lot of that
hormone the pregnancy hormone that's a
good sign and i started getting like
really nauseous like oh my god i've been
like for the last two weeks i've been
extremely nauseous i've never been more
happy for you to be nauseous
it's a really good time and like my
boobs have been hurting and i've been
peeing a lot like every single night
i've been waking up really early like in
the middle of the morning because it's
still early morning and
going to pee and i feel like my bladder
is gonna burst and then also my
heightened sense of smell like now i
kind of smelled it it's like something
like i'm like a superhuman i can smell
like every little thing but yeah these
are all good signs right like good signs
that i'm experiencing all these things
so yeah i'm just so excited like i can't
wait to get
to the office
the first step is to fill out these all
this paperwork for like new pregnancy
paperwork whatever and then after that
like getting in seeing the doctor
hopefully getting to hear a heartbeat
like oh my god that's the moment that
i'm just like
fast forward like get to that point
right now we've been counting the hours
to this appointment like oh my god every
day we're like oh my god three more days
oh we got two more days oh my god six
more hours
we're just so eager to get there already
we're almost there wish us luck
how you feeling uh
nervous yeah well i don't know if we're
gonna get an ultrasound but we'll see
or we're not doing the ultrasound thing
today i mean we should
but i'm seeing a nurse i don't know why
like they didn't have me see my doctor
no
i don't know maybe because of the last
time it was a chemical pregnancy so they
were like let's just make sure you're
pregnant first uh
so
i think that's why i wanted my pee i
have no idea what's going on i just know
i was told to wait and halfway for the
past like 30 minutes standing there by
myself while you're
doing your thing in here
i'm excited to be inside the club now
because of covet procedures they have
like a staff member outside the door and
she's like playing bouncer i was just
telling casey as we're waiting here to
be called
um that the 21st
is significant in three different months
so on april 21st is when i had the
miscarriage may 21st was my last period
which is a significant date when you're
pregnant because that's when they start
counting your pregnancy may 21st was my
last pregnancy and then june 21st was
when we found out we were pregnant for
some reason the 21st is like very
significant and then casey was just
saying he's like and february 21st maybe
is when we might have this baby 20 22
yeah 2022 but who knows we'll see as you
were vlogging and this is like the first
time we're vlogging and like actively
talking about
this pregnancy the pregnancy and stuff
and like i don't know something about
just putting it on video makes it feel
way more real now all the other days we
talked about it's like kind of in secret
it's just between you and me we're not
really telling anyone else and like it
was just sinking in on the way here i
was like
yo we're pregnant
i don't think it's really going to sink
in for me until i hear a heartbeat
that's what's going to really confirm it
for me true
i'm waiting for that i know being in
this room is also an experience
i've never been in a doctor's office
where there's pregnancy posters that are
all around me oh really find passion
life pursuit like that's that's all like
mother like parent things you know oh i
see it all the time every time i come
get my like checked up
[Music]
it was good but we didn't end up getting
an ultrasound
so we didn't get to see the baby so
next week we get the ultrasound yeah
today was just to meet the team and they
they meet us and you know
pregnancy information i mean they also
did draw blood so it wasn't for nothing
and they also got like my urine
true so you can
analyze my tea
tree nice thanks for checking out that's
so sweet of you
[Music]
i'm in the car with casey
today is july 16th so it's been about a
week since the last time we spoke and as
you heard in the last clip we didn't get
an ultrasound in that last um
appointment but today's appointment is
the ultrasound find a
remember when i think you said when he
was little he used to say
but yeah so finally today we have the
ultrasound we're heading over right now
and i'm nervous i'm so nervous um
i
keep having this weird feeling and like
a lot of signs i don't know if i talked
about this in the last vlog but i've
been having a lot of like weird signs
and feelings that might be having twins
i don't know
um i doubt that we're gonna find out
today though if there is anything
because i just googled it and then they
said that you are gonna have twins they
won't confirm it until like week 10 or
12 and today i turn eight weeks so
that's probably not going to be a thing
but this morning i woke up like at 5 00
am to go pee and our appointment's at
nine but um i was trying to get up at
eight which means that i still had like
three hours to sleep from the time that
i woke up to go pee to the time i woke
up to get ready and in those three hours
i kept dreaming about this appointment
and i just kept having like every
scenario that could happen
i kept dreaming about like
finding out like oh it's like you know
you see the baby and the heartbeat and
everything we're all happy and it's one
baby and we're like oh yay and then
another dream was like oh there's twins
and we're like what that's crazy and
then another scenario was a sadder one
where it's like oh we can't hear the
heartbeat but like every scenario
i dreamt of this morning and
i don't know like very obviously very
clearly that this appointment was on my
mind but now we're getting closer we're
about to be there and actually find out
in real life not just in dreamland
but how do you feel baby yeah i don't
know i've been ever since the the the
miscarriage i guess the chemical
pregnancy like i've been kind of
because i was so excited then when we
found out and like it was like on my
mind on my mind and then this time
around i've kind of suppressed some of
the feelings and excitement because yeah
me too
you know you open open up your heart to
this possibility and
and you don't want to get your hopes up
yeah i don't know and sometimes it's
just
when it doesn't happen it just breaks
your heart and i'm just i got i got my
guards up yeah got my guards up i feel
like that too after today though i feel
like it would lift whatever you know
thing is on me
hopefully uh i don't know i'll feel
better yeah like the main thing that
that will i feel like for both of us
alleviate that
that those concerns is to finally hear a
heartbeat and at eight weeks there for
sure
should be a heartbeat so
we'll see
what happens but it's like really
nerve-racking because
yeah like you want to be excited you
want to
be like oh my gosh i can't wait in all
these things and make plans but then
after going through what we went through
like we're careful we're just like hold
on wait i don't know like nothing's
nothing's guaranteed so yeah i totally
get that but i will say though because
of my symptoms being as strong as they
are
it does give me a lot of hope because
like even right now as i'm speaking i'm
like trying to like swallow the nausea
like i want to throw up so bad
um and and like that wasn't the case
with the the first
with the chemical pregnancy yeah like i
don't know just having these symptoms i
definitely do feel very pregnant i don't
know that kind of gives me hope
that everything will be okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey happy friday
hey
oh sure yeah
okay
yay there's a heartbeat we did it but we
didn't get to hear it
no that was kind of sad because i was
excited too early to hear well that's
what she said but i'm like this office
is weird because usually
in the first appointment they
confirm you're pregnant they do an
ultrasound and you hear
the heartbeat if it's like because i'm
at eight weeks like this is the time
that we would do all those things so
it's kind of weird how this office
separates everything i don't know i'm
not a fan of that
but we did see the flickering and it's
definitely moving yeah and so she was
just saying like oh we're gonna just see
the heartbeat without sound today but
i'm like lady why
bump up the volume like we can hear the
heartbeat but yeah we got to
see a heartbeat not hear a heartbeat she
was like yup you're definitely pregnant
and there's definitely one baby and i'm
like okay cool there's one baby okay we
could get all that twin stuff out of my
head now but yeah it's so tiny and then
these photos it reminds me of when
isaac was little and i got the very
first ultrasound photos of him he was
this tiny and now it's like oh my god
your sibling is this tiny
how cute oh my gosh i wonder we're gonna
have
i have a feeling it's a boy but
i don't even know anymore because my mom
thinks it's a girl so does my aunt and
you know mexican moms
they're they're brucas they know for
some reason they always get it right so
we could be having a girl who knows
he's too focused yeah i thought i was
gonna cry i'm surprised i didn't cry i
think if i would have heard the
heartbeat it would have made me cry but
i almost cried when i saw the flickering
because i'm like oh my god it has a
heartbeat and it's healthy and yeah she
confirmed it um due date is february
25th
that's crazy
that's so crazy is it sinking in now
finally that we're having a baby i've
been feeling
very pregnant already with these there's
nausea with this intense
tiredness like i just feel like i've
been in a foggy haze i just i feel like
i'm not here it's really weird like i
don't feel very present with life right
now i feel really tired really nauseous
my body hurts like my boobs hurt
like i definitely have all the pregnancy
symptoms right now and i've been very
like airheaded too i've been i've been
having so many moments where i'm like oh
my god mommy brain that's crazy but then
now like having these like photos in my
hands it's like oh my gosh it's actually
growing in me like there's like fun i
saw like the heart
beat flicker and like i don't know this
tr like this appointment definitely
made me feel confirmed it's confirmed i
can be happy i can be excited finally
having a baby you guys finally so now
can you answer your question oh yeah uh
yeah i feel
i
elated and
i think it's still sinking in but yeah
i'm gonna be a dad finally happy
[Music]
all right isaac you ready the first look
to your sibling yeah
you're like what am i looking at what
the heck
it's like it looks like a
it's a board
it looks like a uh it's a
a seahorse
it's a tiny hulk yeah it's really tight
it's the size of a raspberry now yeah
it's a little raspberry
[Music]
it's a strong heart
[Music]
you